hey 42 here as you've probably noticed
modern society has something of an
obsession with entrepreneurs so much so
that the likes of elon musk mark
zuckerberg richard branson jack ma and
jeff bezos get more column ninjas in
most newspapers and magazines than your
average hollywood a-lister kids these
days don't dream of being astronauts
they want to be tech billionaires keen
to tap into such lofty ambitions amongst
a modern youth an entire cottage
industry has sprung up almost overnight
with self-help books influencers and
podcasters all promising to tell you
that one thing that every billionaire
does in the morning that'll make you
rich
as if all you have to do to become
wealthy beyond your wildest dreams is
set your alarm for 4am and down a goji
berry smoothie the instant you wake up
in reality of course there is no one
secret trick to becoming a billionaire
or is there
well no there definitely isn't but there
is one thing the vast majority of the
world's most successful entrepreneurs
happen to have in common
including all the ones i mentioned at
the start of this video
i'll give you a clue
it starts with p
and ends
with enus
as unpalatable a truth as that may be to
you we live in a world where practically
every famous entrepreneur is in
possession of one regular sized standard
issue
y chromosome
according to forbes only about 10
percent of the more than two thousand
billion as on the planet are women but
you don't have to go all that far back
in history to find yourself in a time
when the list of the richest people in
the world would have been even more
overwhelmingly male
overwhelmingly male
but not entirely
hetty green was an american
businesswoman who made a fortune on wall
street in the 1800s
decades before women were even allowed
to vote
rage shadow legends has taken over and
gaming will never be the same again raid
is the first game to bring a true
console level experience to your phone
they've set the bar high and there's no
going back recently i've been really
enjoying playing with the rare champion
judge from the dark elves faction i'm
also a huge fan of turvol from the
barbarian faction quite simply he's one
of the hardest hitting champions in the
entire game with some builds he can hit
for over 400k damage
so what's new in raid well they're
bringing out five badass looking new
champions that i can't wait to get my
hands on they've also brought out new
skins for one of my favorite champions
trunder guilt mallet and they just look
awesome and raid's currently running a
special deliana chase event where you
can get your hands on the amazing
deliana a brand new legendary champion
from the high elves faction all you have
to do is log in and play raid for seven
days between now and july the 28th and
you'll get deliana for free this is the
best time to get started in raid and you
can click my link in the description
below or scan my qr code here on the
screen and you'll get unique bonuses
worth 30 dollars we're talking a free
epic champion verges 200k silver
one energy refill and one xp boost and
one ancient shard so you can summon
awesome champions as soon as you get in
game all this treasure will be waiting
for you here all new players listen up
once you're in game just enter the code
my deliana to get your hands on
everything and i'll see you in game
thanks to rage shadow legends for
sponsoring this video
but being a woman didn't change how much
she liked holding on to her money
in fact when it came to passing with
cash this millionaire was tighter than
your wife runs after an episode of
bridgeton and that's not just my opinion
the guinness book of world records named
her the planet's greatest miser
[Music]
as if being recognized as the biggest
cheapskate on earth isn't enough petty
is also commonly remembered as the witch
of wall street and not just for her
ability to make money appear out of thin
air no it was a deliberately mean
nickname
because even though she probably wasn't
the easiest person to get along with
hetty was also a woman who flourished in
a man's world
she lived in a time when society
expected well-to-do members of the
fairer sex to
look pretty smile and leave the
important things in life to the nearest
man
instead hetty carried a gun cussed like
a sailor and objected to masculine
control
famously making her husband sign a
prenuptial agreement so that he'd have
no claim on her money should things go
south
that kind of thing might work for
beyonce but a century and a half ago it
was practically unheard of
but despite the many negative stories
we're going to hear about hetty she
actually had quite a few redeeming
features we just need to look a bit
harder to find them hetty was born into
a wealthy massachusetts whaling family
in 1834
her younger brother died as a baby and
her mother was often ill so hetty spent
much of her childhood living with her
grandparents and it was her grandfather
gideon who gave her her first lessons in
commerce
he had dodgy eyes and so six-year-old
hetty used to read the finance section
of the newspaper to him
with gideon providing a running
commentary on the news of the day
including why certain stocks were a good
investment and others weren't
young hetty also accompanied her
grandfather and father down to the docks
where they did their business dealings
which had the combined effect of
teaching hetty a good deal about both
the art of negotiation and the science
of swearing like a sailor after half a
liter of room
she also learned her way around the
business's ledgers by the age of 13 she
was skilled enough to act as her
father's bookkeeper as well as how to
run a business petty's father taught her
how to invest and generally how to look
after money
which is how years later when he
transitions the family business from
whaling oil to shipping cargo hetty
would be a crucial part of building an
impressive portfolio of real estate
stocks and bonds
to complete this somewhat untraditional
school of life education
hetti was privately tutored and attended
a quaker boarding school but those docs
had clearly left their imprint on the
girl because her aunt sylvia insisted
she attend the finishing school in the
hope of turning young hetty into a lady
as was the way of the times the entire
system was designed to secure girls a
decent husband
hetty was said to be an attractive young
woman so her father was keen to see her
marry well he bought her a wardrobe of
lovely dresses to attract a suitable
well suitor
but hetty was having none of that she
sold the gowns and invested the money in
government bonds
instead despite her best efforts hetty
still managed to attract her fair share
of admirers and it was while staying
with her father in new york after the
death of her mother that hetty met
someone she admired back her future
husband edward green
green was a wealthy businessman so at
least he and hetty had that in common
but he was fond of a high life and
spending money
a passion they certainly didn't share
hetty lived at a time when married women
weren't seen as full and individual
people in the eyes of the law
women had no right to vote and the
married woman's property was legally
controlled by her husband for this
reason hetty's father included a clause
in his will that stated any husband of
hetty's wasn't to inherit the money he
left to her
he needn't have worried though hetty had
no interest in dishing out her wealth
and made edward sign an agreement that
would keep their finances separate
it would prove to be an astute move but
more on that later
hetty inherited around seven million
dollars from her father when he passed
away in 1865 worth about 125 million
dollars today
but by her father's requirements the
bulk of the fortune was to be kept in a
trust fund that hetty had no control
over
later in the same year her aunt sylvia
also died leaving hetid inheritance from
her wealthy grandfather gideon
but just like her father's will and
sylvia's contained a few nasty surprises
around half of the money one million
dollars was to be left to charity and
the rest was to be kept in yet another
inaccessible trust fund
even considering the trust fund and
charity donations petty had still
inherited an incredible fortune but as
far as she was concerned that wasn't the
point
she'd been cheated out of what was
rightfully hers and she was going to get
it back
even if doing so involved a little
cheating of her own
aunt sylvia's will had been finalized in
1863
but conveniently enough hetty managed to
dig up an older copy of the document
dated 1862
in which the entire fortune was left to
her
even more conveniently that will
contained a nifty little clause that
confirmed any future wills were null and
void
a five-year legal battle ensued but
eventually the signatures on hetty's
version of the will
were declared to be forgeries they must
have been pretty bad ones too because
forensic analysis of the pen strokes
concluded that the odds of the
signatures being genuine were about one
in two and a half sextillion
despite having apparently scribbled her
aunt's name on a fake will in wax
crayons for some reason hetty was never
charged with fraud perhaps because she
buggered off to london for a few years
till the heat died down but she'd
certainly learned her lesson about the
world of counterfeiting
in her future business dealings she
would never again sign her name
always asking others to sign on her
behalf so that nobody could ever copy
her signature and swindle her
by now hesi was an active investor and
used the interest from her father's
trust fund to grow her wealth
exponentially
she invested heavily in railroads real
estate and government bonds and
according to her success was just a case
of buying when stock was low and selling
it when it was high
so that's where we've been going wrong
all this time
in contrast to hetty's style her husband
was rather more cavalier and he made
some bad investments that led to
significant losses
despite her reputation as the world's
greatest miser hetty had the patience
and generosity of a saint when it came
to her husband
bailing him out on multiple times over
the years
but in 1885 edward made a fatal mistake
no doubt embarrassed about finding
himself in a sticky financial spot once
again he secretly withdrew just over
half a million dollars from one of
hetty's accounts
the bank refused to transfer but for
hetty the act was unforgivable and the
couple separated
[Music]
at the time hetty was worth around 26
million dollars that's three quarters of
a billion in 2022 but despite wealth
that most people literally can't imagine
she lived like she was on the breadline
using various aliases hetty moved
between apartments hotels and boarding
houses so she could avoid paying
property tax
she didn't want to rent an office so she
worked from the chemical bank one of the
companies she was invested in where she
could be found managing her business
from a vacant desk
and when one of those wasn't available
from the floor when hetty had oats for
lunch she'd put the bowl on the radiator
to save the cost of heating the water on
the stove
it's also said that she saved money by
requesting that only the hems of her
dresses be cleaned because those were
the only parts that got dirty
well i say dresses apparently hetty only
actually had one dress at a time which
she'd wear until it basically fell apart
when her estranged husband died in 1902
that dress became a black one and it was
then that the witch of wall street's
nickname really took hold
probably the most widely reported story
of penny pinching involved hetty's son
ned who suffered a broken leg in a
sledging accident as a child
hetty initially took him to a clinic for
the poor where medical care was free but
she was eventually recognized and ned's
treatment was withdrawn
many accounts claim that hetty decided
to care for ned at home rather than pay
for treatment though some other sources
suggest she probably did try and find
alternative doctors
whatever the exact details ned's leg
didn't heal properly gangrene set in and
eventually the limb had to be amputated
interestingly enough ned seems to have
been one of his mother's biggest fans
he gave several interviews during the
course of his life and he painted a very
different picture of the world famous
miser who may or may not have cost him
his leg
according to him hetty supported
numerous charities with sums that today
would run into hundreds of thousands of
dollars she also loaned money to about
30 churches at below market interest
rates and she paid dozens of families a
regular income to help them manage their
living expenses
hetty was also very loyal to those close
to her a bookkeeper named benjamin
lawton worked for her father before
working for her and hetty kept him on
the payroll well into his old age even
though most of his day was spent
snoozing at his desk
according to ned the reason nobody knew
about any of these good deeds was simple
hetty believed in what she called
discreet charity she did good things
because she wanted to not because she
thought it would play well with
investors shareholders and the press
in the early part of the 20th century a
financial crisis known as the panic of
1907 shook wall street wiping 50 after
value of the new york stock exchange in
the space of just three weeks
true to form hetty saw the crash coming
and not only did she safeguard the bulk
of her fortune from the repercussions
she also had plenty of cash on hands to
loan to those in need
most businesses in america lost money
during the panic of 1907 but hetty only
got richer
so rich in fact that during the worst of
the market crash she actually bailed out
the city of new york with a massive loan
over the following years she a private
individual would become the city's
largest lender
hetty finally cashed in her chips in
1916 at the age of 81 with an estimated
net worth of close to five billion
dollars in today's terms
that made her easily the richest woman
in america and very probably the entire
world in many ways it's hard to know
what to make of this remarkable woman
for the most part history seems to have
remembered her as a bit of a villain and
her outrageous stinginess was admittedly
pretty unforgivable after all the best
thing the ultra wealthy can do is spend
their cash to help the economy
but it does her memory a disservice to
focus only on the negatives
this was a woman who flagrantly ignored
the oppressive sexist customs of her
times to do things her own way a woman
who played the men of wall street at
their own game and absolutely
obliterated them while she was at it
and most of all a woman who deliberately
chose to keep the many good things she
did for her friends neighbors and the
city to herself
in the days when doing a good deed is
only worth it if you can immediately
post it on social media i think that's
pretty cool
thanks for watching